as you know we are currently
crowdfunding Snow White and the Widow
queen and I thought that in this context
would be a great idea to put out some
old Patron only videos that interpret
fairy tales it gives you an idea of what
it is that you can find when you support
the symbolic world but this one in
particular is the strangest of all it is
the story of Rumpelstiltskin and I
interpret it in relationship to
understanding how credit works you know
it sounds very strange but it'll help
you kind of understand what it means to
borrow from the future what it means to
borrow from the strange and what cost
that has and what opportunities that
brings so this will be the last video
that we're going to put out in this
series interpreting fairy tales uh if
you haven't backed Snow White and the
Widow Queen please do it now because
it's the time is getting short and uh
and enjoy
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody I am currently in
Charleston South Carolina I come here
every year to do some work with my
collaborator and good friend Andrew
Gould who's an architect I have an
interview with him on my channel if you
want to check that out but I thought I
would take some time to make uh this
video that I've been planning for a
while and it's a video on
Rumpelstiltskin the symbolism of
Rumpelstiltskin you will see that I'm
gonna take you guys I'm taking you guys
to expert level symbolic interpretation
here and so hopefully I'll be able to
pull it all together and hopefully uh
you'll be able to get something from it
now one of the things I like about the
symbol the story of Rumpelstiltskin is
just how strange it is I really love the
strange fairy tales because uh and also
the strange verses and the strange parts
of the Bible because that's the place
where you can surprise people the most
and show them that no actually despite
the fact that it looks completely off
the wall and weird uh the structure of
the story is actually quite coherent now
the story of Rumpelstiltskin I'll tell
you the basics of the story as I usually
do and then we'll go into the
interpretation so the story starts with
the idea that some poor man is uh is
brought before the king he is um
he's presented for the king for some
reason I forget what it is I don't think
it's very important in the story and
while he's speaking to the king he makes
this boast which is that his daughter
can produce we can uh thread straw into
gold and so he kind of does this
boasting and the King you know when he
hears this he says okay well then you
have to bring your daughter to me so
that you can do that for me and now the
uh the poor man is caught in his
boasting and has to uh put up of course
he he knows this is not possible this is
impossible for for you to thread uh
straw into gold but nonetheless he's
forced because it's the king because of
all because he's he has no choice he
brings his daughter to the king and he
presents her to her so her the poor
man's daughter is caught in this
situation despite herself and so the
King touser he's going to put her in a
room and a room full of straw and he had
and she has to thread this straw into
gold before the end of the night or else
he's going to kill her and uh so it's
yeah of course so this this young lady
is there at night alone in this room and
she starts to cry and she starts to weep
uh that she can't do this and then
that's when this small strange bearded
man appears Rumpelstiltskin who he
doesn't say his name of course he
appears and he makes a deal with the
lady he says
you have to give me something if you
give me something then I will be able to
change this straw into gold and so you
know she has a necklace or a bracelet
and so she gives this to Rumpelstiltskin
and Rumpelstiltskin works all night
threading this straw changing it into
gold of course the next day when the
king discovers this the king is
extremely happy but as most people he
he's just sees that he could get more
and so he brings her to a second room
that's just even bigger and has more
straw and he tells her that she has to
do it again and if she doesn't he's
going to kill her so once again she
cries and cries Rumpelstiltskin appears
the same deal Make a Deal Exchange
something for him to change strong to
Gold she exchanges another piece of
jewelry and then finally
he works all night and once again he is
successful and once again the king sees
this and just like all fairy tales the
rule of three it has to happen three
times the third time the uh the the the
the princess goes in and she's crying
she's crying but now she has nothing
left she has no jewelry she has nothing
to give Rumpelstiltskin uh and so the
king also says that this time if you
don't succeed of course I'm gonna kill
you if you do succeed I will marry you
and so there she is in this room
desperate and Rumpelstiltskin appears
again but she has nothing to offer and
so Rumplestiltskin tells her that she
has to give him her firstborn when her
firstborn uh comes to be in the future
of course
and for those who have followed my
videos you probably know what this is
about or what's going on here but try to
figure it out as I'm telling the story
hopefully you'll get some hints
um and so the princess is desperate you
know she has no solution and so you know
despite herself she agrees to this deal
and Rumpelstiltskin does it here you go
there's the gold and the King marries
her very strange situation the king
marries the woman that he wanted to kill
the nonetheless the princess Mary's the
king and you know they live their life
and of course as per the usual ways she
gets pregnant and she has a child when
she has a child what do you think
happens rumpelsticles rumpelstilston
Rumpelstiltskin shows up and demands the
child
so the woman cries and cries and weeps
and says please please don't take my
child away what can I do there must be
something you know you know give me a
chance or whatever and then
Rumpelstiltskin proposes that if she is
able in three days to discover his name
then he will leave her with her child if
she is not if she is not able to
discover his name then that's it the end
of the deal he keeps the baby
and so rumpelstilton goes away and says
he'll come back once and every day and
she has three chances three three days
to find his name so of course the the
princess goes to work but you know by
this time she's the queen I guess this
queen goes to work and uh and and gets
you know tries to gather in all the
names that she can imagine all the names
you can find she asks her servants to
gather all the names in the Kingdom you
know to figure out you know what name
it's a win rumpelstilson arrives she has
this list of all these names that she
was able to find so she starts to say is
it Robert is it George is it Patrick and
she goes on and on she goes down the
listen Every Time Rumpelstiltskin says
nope nope nope that's not it nope that's
not it goes through all the names and of
course she doesn't succeed rumpelst
kills still skin of course finds this
extremely amusing is Overjoyed by this
and says well I'll be back tomorrow
we'll see if you can do it tomorrow so
he leaves she sends now her her um
her servants to all the adjoining
Kingdom so all the kingdoms nearby to
try to figure out all the different
names that she didn't account for in her
own list so they go out and they go a
little further out and the names are
becoming a little stranger different
names they write them down make lists
bring them back to the princess and once
again the princess starts the naming
process when Rumpelstiltskin arrives is
it
I I don't know is it Vladimir is it uh
she starts finding the stranger names
that are from further away you know
um
and robot silicon says nope that's not
it no that's not it no that's not it and
of course once again on the third day
now she sends them out to the furthest
regions of the world to the furthest
areas of all the kingdoms that are far
away that nobody knows much about to
gather all the names and to bring them
back to the princess so she has all
these names and she's afraid because
she's wondering is she going to be able
to do it is she going to find
Rumpelstiltskin's name and then her last
servant arrived just before
Rumpelstiltskin does and says that he
got lost and he he wandered and he got
lost in this forest and then in this
Dark Forest he heard the this this
little imp that was running around a
fire and was singing to himself that he
was going to have the the the The
Queen's child and that he was going to
have a baby for himself and he says and
and he and he says something like you
know and she wouldn't able to be to fool
Rumpelstiltskin something like that but
he says his name that's the point is
that as he's boasting to himself as he's
kind of boasting of his success he says
his name and so the the servant says
maybe that's it like that must be his
name so of course the queen now she
she's got her tool and Rumpelstiltskin
comes in and he says this is it this is
your last chance and she starts she
thought she gives a few names at the
beginning to to get him on his way to
say nope that's not it no that's not it
and then finally she says is it
Rumpelstiltskin and then
the Imp at first is just gonna say no
but then he realized that no she got it
she got his name and so there's
different versions like he becomes
really Furious sometimes he vanishes in
a puff of smoke or he leads and makes a
hole in the in the floor as he goes away
but finally the queen succeeds and is
able to keep her child all right
so what is this about
I imagine some of you might have gotten
to the fact that this has something to
do with this discussion about credit
that I've been talking about
um
and so rubble's still skin this it all
starts with the proposition of something
which is impossible
the the the the boasting of the the
possibility of something which is not
possible okay now you have to think of
that in terms of what borrowing means
right what credit means because that's
something that's pretty much why we
borrow in the first place it's like I
want to buy a car that's not possible I
don't have the money so what do I do in
order to have access to that car is I'm
going to borrow right I'm going to
borrow from the future in order to be
able to have the card now so so so that
that that's the beginning of the
problems he proposes something
impossible
so you can understand in terms of this
credit but you can also understand it in
terms of of uh of a scientist who
imagines something impossible like uh
you know like let's go to the Moon you
know like we're I can go to the Moon
something like that and so that
possibility doesn't exist within the
world right now and so the only way to
get that possibility is to increase your
reach you could say to to reach out into
the future to reach out into the outside
to reach out further than what you are
and to be able to gather that to
yourself in order to accomplish this
this this boasting that you've done this
this proposition this imagination or
whatever uh but so on the one hand the
the image of turning straw into gold is
an image of something impossible but on
the other hand It's actually an image of
it's an image of the purpose of
everything now what do I mean by that
the idea of changing straw into gold is
the same as the uh you know the the idea
of uh changing lead into gold that we
find you know in uh in ancient Sciences
uh and it's also the idea if you want to
understand why how this notion of
changing straw into gold it can help you
understand for example why is it that
Christ was put into a Manger why is it
that Christ was put into the food trough
for Animals because straw that's all
that it's useful for it's not useful for
our food it's it's lower than us right
it's it's it's like uh it's it's the uh
the remainder it's the grass of the
field you know it's uh it's it's like
this dust or whatever it's not that
which we can integrate but it's lower
than us and you can see it as this
notion that it's something that animals
can integrate and so this image of
Christ in the manger is the same idea of
taking that which is the lowest and
turning it into the highest I I've
telling you guys about this for months
now that changing death into Glory that
is that is the purpose of everything
right and so
and you find it in in images like that
so so so here's this useless thing this
straw this this kind of the lowest thing
and so the question is can you change
that into gold can you change the lowest
into the highest the last into the first
and that's the that's the that's the
transition spot that's the place where
something ends something begins there's
a mysterious thing that happens you know
the sun sets the sun rises the the the
the solstice where the sun is the lowest
and flips into the highest the seed
which falls into the ground and dies but
then becomes a tree it's like all those
images like how is it that something
that's the lowest can flip Can chant can
turn into that which is the highest how
can the ornament you know become the
crown all of all of this this is this is
this is the one of the biggest mysteries
in the world really and so the story of
Rumpelstiltskin is dealing with this
mystery and so what imagery does it
propose
first of all it's important to
understand that the the the the
transformation happens at night that's
all that's very important so you can
imagine the transformation happening in
the bottom of the ocean where Jonah is
in the whale and and then he he repents
he he flips and then he comes back out
you can imagine it as Christ in the Tomb
who who mysteriously something something
flips and then he resurrects now
it has to happen at night just like the
sun is is gone at night but then it's
out of night that the Sun comes back up
again and so it happens at night that
the time when we're supposed to rest at
the time where we're not supposed to
work so there's a there this there's
this upside down thing going on where
the the Imp is working at night
and and that is the opposite of what
should happen you see that in several
other stories like the the Shoemaker and
the elves where where you know while
you're resting or while uh while the
world is supposed to rest there's a
secret work that's happening okay
that is that is one two is the very
image of the wheel this very image of
the the threading wheel that that
changes uh the straw into gold that is
also this image of the of the change
right it's it's an image of you could
call it an image of of change itself
um
and it is related also this this change
is of course related to to death and
what I'm trying to suggest you that it's
related to death but also to
Resurrection you see that in uh of
course this idea of the relationship
between the the threading wheel and uh
and death you see it in the story of
Sleeping Beauty
um but you see it in this in this
situation as well the
the life of the princess is in the
balance it's kind of up in the air right
it's it's uh we it's uncertain we don't
know if she's going to come out of the
box
alive or dead so in this moment of
uncertainty that's when that's when this
transformation is going to to happen now
then we have the the the the the
question of
of borrowing from the future
so this is how it presents itself in
this story so there's this idea she
makes uh she she in the problem of the
of the the uh of the impossibility the
only way she can do it is to go and take
from
you to take from the future but also at
the same type time to take from this
monster or to take from this foreign
agent you know this agent of the unknown
she has to be able to go in there and
get something from that but it has a
it's dangerous it has a price you can
see it in terms of the problem of
borrowing right we talk about it in the
video on credit the problem of borrowing
uh is that you
you run the risk that your fruit is
going to go to that foreign that foreign
agent that that outside thing you know
there's some Proverbs that talk about
that this idea that you should not go to
the strange woman you should not go to
the to the to the
to this kind of foreign woman because
the risk is that if you unite yourself
with the strange then you run the rift
that your seed your fruit is going to
profit the outside you know and that's
exactly the situation here because
Rumpelstiltskin she's borrowing from
Rumpelstiltskin but she she is running
the risk of making herself uh
subservient to Rumpelstiltskin she's
running the risk of putting herself
yoking herself to Rumpelstiltskin and
that will then
the possibility that her future fruit is
going to go to him it's not it's not
crazy to imagine like to think of when
you borrow money from the bank what are
you doing you're borrowing money from
the bank and it means that you as you're
paying the bank back and you're paying
back interest your future work your the
future fruit of your labor is going to
the bank you know and and more than what
you borrowed and so you're although
although it can be useful sometimes it's
dangerous because you you don't realize
that the money that you're making in the
future that you're actually making less
because you're paying interest on your
loan you're constantly giving some of
your value some of your fruit to this
outside uh this outside element from
which you borrowed the future from the
bank you know whatever
um
and so this is this is the situation
that is being set up in the story of
Rumpelstiltskin it's really showing us
the let's say this this structure of of
of the problem of increasing your
possibility how does this happen how
does it shift and what's the danger in
this kind of this kind of this
transformation of straw into gold
because it's not it's like I said I keep
trying to be telling him to be careful
like it's neither positive or negative
you have to just understand the
structure but just as
okay so so she borrows from
Rumpelstiltskin right she she owes him
something and she owes him her future
son which is an image of of everything
it's an image of all her future all her
future identity you could call she's
making herself subservient to
Rumpelstiltskin because it's not just
her son that's going to go to
Rumpelstiltskin but the King's son so
it's like she's giving the King's son
the Future King is becoming subservient
to this outside dark Forest okay
um
and that's because she was willing to to
borrow
from him in order to meet this
impossible requirement right to to meet
something that needed to happen but that
was impossible all right hope you guys
are following me until here so that's
the first part of the story now she's in
trouble because when she has the child
then
she she uh
how can I say this then should be to
subservient to him but you you also have
to understand that this changing of the
straw into gold is not just about the
straw into gold it's also about her it's
about how she has this lower as this
peasant girl has also been transformed
into the queen right it's not just the
strong to Gold her her trip is the same
trip as the straw into gold and so she's
able to become the Queen by engaging in
this about engaging in this dubious
transaction right
um transaction that has given her value
now but that is putting her in trouble
for later but now she has to solve the
problem so it's like a
you could call it that's this whole
flipping thing that's going on right so
it's a strange situation she's the queen
she's become the Queen by making herself
subservient to others now this this is
not don't
this is very not there's nothing strange
about this this has happened all the
time in history where someone who wants
to become king or who thinks that they
should be king they Ally themselves with
a foreign power in order to be able to
displace the king that's there and
replace the King right this is not some
this is something which happens all the
time in terms of politics but it is it
is also a transaction which which you
could operate on a smaller scale as well
um
but understanding it in terms of the
king you know the the king who the
person who wants to be king but can't
allying themselves with a foreign power
replacing the king but now once he's got
gotten what he wants he's in trouble
because he is also at the same time he's
made himself subservient to that that
outer power that foreign power okay
um you can understand it that way now
how does she
solve the problem now
she solves the problem by learning the
foreign names learning names now this
idea of learning names really is this
this capacity to master things to to uh
foreign
in the traditional notion to know
something's name to know someone's name
is to to somehow have
to be not necessarily to have power over
it but to have some power over it to
have some capacity to engage with it to
commune with it it's no longer see it
this way it's no longer a dark chaotic
potential right if you know the name of
something then now it has integrated
into your world and knowing the name of
something can can mean mastering a skill
that you don't have uh you know it can
mean all kinds of things like You're
increasing your capacity to go further
out into the world and that's how she
has to do it now the problem is that
Rumpelstiltskin comes from
the end of the world you could say he's
a mother from the end of the world and
so she she wants to get to him she wants
to be able to master Rumpelstiltskin but
so so to do that she has to increase her
capacity and and and Conquer you could
call it conquering she has to conquer
all these names right she has to master
these names and so she moves out out of
her her sphere of knowledge and she
starts to know the names of the things
that are outside so she grows her her
influence her capacity to understand and
she what her purpose is to get to
Rumpelstiltskin now
that's that's
ultimately right that's ultimately an
image of the Resurrection right that is
what we
when we talk about Christ descending
into Hades right going to the bottom of
death but he does it in a manner in
which he he becomes the master of death
by by descending into death it's like
bringing light into darkness and so he
illuminates the darkness all the way
till the edge and going all the way to
the edge you have to go all the way to
the end you have to go all the way to
the end and then that's when the
the resurrection can
can occur right the sun has to go all
the way down on the solstice to the
bottom of the world and then that's when
the mystery occurs and it comes back out
so she's she's going all the way out
she's she's moving out trying to find
Rumpelstiltskin's name trying to master
all this potentiality around her and so
it takes
three days
am I do I really I don't have to tell
you why it takes three days uh you know
of course three is a number in all fairy
tales but
that's also this is the reason why three
is a is a number in a lot of fairy tales
is a similar reason to why Christ is
three days in the Tomb so it takes three
days she reaches going further and
further out and finally in the dark
forest in this kind of surprises this
unexpected moment that that the the
servant actually got lost right he keeps
coming right to the edge right to the
end that's when he encounters the name
of Rumpelstiltskin
and he brings it back to her so that she
now can Master uh Rumpelstiltskin and
that brings about the resurrection of
the king now right you you have to
understand it that the King was it was
was dying that is the the son of the
King was his fruit was going to be Cast
Away cast out to the outside and now by
reaching by by her reaching out and
reaching to the edge and finding
Rumpelstiltskin's name she she uh she's
able to resurrect the seed of the king
and
it happens also in the way that I've
tried to explain it to you before it
happens as tricking the trickster right
because it's so satisfying to imagine
that moment when she is talking to
Rumpelstiltskin uh and that last day
where Rumpelstiltskin is so arrogant and
thinks that he's got it and she's naming
these names but he's like no no no and
then finally she says Rumpelstiltskin
and it's like that moment where the
trickster is tricked is so satisfying
but it's so satisfying because it is it
has that idea that that's how the world
starts again like that's the that's the
that's the last trick that's how that's
that's Christ going into Hades and Hades
thinks that he's won and he thinks that
oh I finally done it right I've brought
Christ into death but then the trickster
is tricked and the death of Christ
actually is like I said bringing light
into darkness and so when he he thought
he won but by the very fact of winning
he's lost and so
so you see a little bit of that of
course Christ story is a million times
more but you see a little bit of that
structure in this in the manner in which
the Rumpelstiltskin narrative concludes
let's say
um
and so I think that I I'm hoping that
this has given you some food for thought
um like I said this is really a this is
Master Level symbolism because it's it's
like I said it's not about credit it's
not about borrowing it's not about but
all those things like borrowing like
credit like a a kingdom which which uh
compromises Itself by making itself
subservient to a foreign power all these
these parallel structures they're
they're there I'm I'm bringing them up
in order for you to be able to see the
pattern because the pattern is beyond
all of these these particulars right
they manifest themselves in the
different particulars so it's not that
the story of Rumpelstiltskin is about
credit or about this or about that it's
more that it it shares the pattern of
these different elements of reality it
and often because the story is so
strange we can't see that pattern so
well but as we start to see the
analogies between the different other
stories we're able to understand
um
how this is manifesting a common pattern
and how that pattern is in fact a
a pattern of reality and ultimately
maybe it is the one of the ultimate
patterns of reality which is how does
the bottom become the top how does the
end become the beginning how does the
lowest how do we transform the you know
it's like
this is going to sound but how does how
does a little seed you know planted in
dung planted in excrement how does that
become a
tree right that's the how does that
happen right in terms of pattern right
not in terms of the the the the the
chemical things that happen but that
pattern is the same as these other
patterns of turning and of cycling and a
flipping all right so guys I hope you
enjoyed this
um and uh thank you all for your support
these videos are being put out for
patrons only and so I really appreciate
your support as you know I'm still in
kind of a chaotic situation our house
has not yet been uh renovated
um and so we're still in transition it's
been difficult for me to carve so your
support has been extremely helpful in
helping me to keep going so thanks again
guys and I will see you soon
[Music]
I'm Jonathan Pedro and I'm inviting you
to participate with us in our retelling
and our celebration of one of the most
iconic fairy tales of all Snow White a
beautifully Illustrated storybook Snow
White and the Widow Queen places our
iconic character at the beginning of
eight upcoming fairy tales which will
speak to each other and harmonize in
surprising ways Snow White and the Widow
Queen rekindles an adventure which will
make you remember ReDiscover but also
Marvel and wonder at our Rich Heritage
of stories a Heritage that still has
secrets to reveal even after centuries
of being passed down to us in the past
few decades we have watched many of our
stories our fairy tales our myths become
completely exhausted by efforts to
deconstruct them to reinvent them and
sometimes to even invert their original
meaning
it has come to a point where we've
almost forgotten why we cared about
these stories in the first place
I firmly believe that for this reason it
is now time to retell and redisrupt our
original fairy tales in a spirit of
celebration of admiration and unashamed
Jewelry
I've spent the past two decades
meditating on the strange narrative
elements of Snow White and other fairy
tales after much thinking I'm now
bringing this story to our common Hearth
we find in the fire of time ready to
present Hidden Treasures most of us have
never noticed to accomplish this I have
paired up with Heather paulinton a
world-class artist and designer who has
worked on some of the most beloved film
franchises of our time her work mirrors
my writing and a collaboration that has
produced a powerful synthesis of
medieval style with the best of 19th and
20th Century illustration I love the
kickstarter model because we can make
the book more and more beautiful with
every stretch book who can offer art
prints a limited edition drawing by
Heather and even a snow white
illustration of my own
we're planning a super exclusive
leather-bound Edition which pulls out
all the stops a storybook mantelpiece
for sure
the profits of this crowdfunder will be
used to start a new Publishing Company
symbolic World Press who's christening
publication will be this very fairy tale
series
each book illustrated by world-class
artist Jack and the Beanstalk Cinderella
the Valiant little Taylor and several
more are next in line for publication
all existing in the same world and all
fitting together like a puzzle moving
towards the final surprising resolution
after all that there's no limit to what
we can do
it's time to reset the clock to retell
our stories so please join us in this
celebration and create Adventure
[Music]